okay so I noticed it's so interesting I
go on Twitter and sometimes I just see
these old rants about me so there's this
chick named Lisa
Elizabeth these chicks these chicks all
right so this girl named Lisa says do
you know why I can't stand Pearl there's
so many women out there like me who have
lived a life that internalized feminism
and didn't even realize it
okay so this is an X I'm just taking
notes here I'm taking taking notes so
this is an X feminist all right that
didn't know they're out here making
changes to their lives and trying to be
good Christlike moral
women do you see like trying it's not
it's so interesting when you really
analyze women's language are they being
good Christlike moral
women or are they trying because there's
there's a
different and she just shits all over
them
receipts receipts please okay Pearl I
just want I want to write down my
complaints I like I like to know I'm
just filing the complaints Pearl
shits on
women all
right if if anything she'll push women
to be more
feminist Pearl
says be a feminist I've never heard that
come out of my mouth but okay okay yes
women today are under the spell of
feminism and don't realize it you're
telling me these only fans chicks have
no idea that that's the wrong
decision 4% of women are either on only
fans or do cam work that doesn't include
the women that have done sex work on
Instagram and other light forms of sex
work um I would argue it's closer to 10%
and they have zero
idea really Lisa really it's so funny
it's like I'm the one who has I I hardly
doubt in the last two years she's
interviewed 600 plus women and
men yeah they always think they know
better it's so interesting okay they
have been told to deny their biological
nature well it's not my fault they do
only fans okay they were lied to told
they need to be equal and independent
that being a mother shouldn't be a
priority all to the detriment of both
men and
women
okay you know it's so interesting you
can kind of see how accountable a woman
is by how she analyzes Society you know
it's so interesting because think about
this who makes the culture who's
responsible for the culture if women
have the authority in most households
and there's more women raising children
than than men who is responsible for the
culture if women have been given more
freedom than ever who is responsible for
society now you could argue that it's
the simps that let us do that
but this chick will blame feminism
instead of the women and it's
interesting because what you'll see is
women that think like this tend to do
that in their own personal life too
nothing's ever their fault
feminism lied to me and had made me make
those choices it was feminism not me so
you know interesting
okay okay of course women should submit
to their husbands yes true okay but
telling women to blindly submit to any
man no God and no understanding of
serving his wife has left many women
used oh but do you see that gosh I just
cannot stand I cannot stand women that
will blame everybody else but themselves
women left women used alone and abused
and back to hating men if if women are
in that situation women did it to
themselves no I'm not going to blame
feminism no no no no I blame choices I I
blame individual choices and what you're
going to notice here is it's
never my choices led to this it's well
feminism lied to us now would actually
more than feminism what I would actually
if I was going to you know default blame
which I certainly can a little bit I
would actually put it more on because
the mothers did lie to their daughters
the mothers did we have like we do have
like three generations of shitty wives
but you know I could also think of many
women and men that had shitty parents
and didn't do the wrong
thing like if you're dad tells you to be
a criminal and you choose to be a
criminal I mean are we going to blame
the guy or are we going to blame the the
dad okay the notion of submitting to a
man who has no like it's so gosh he's
women write paragraphs it's like and
it's so interesting so I'm like aren't
these chicks married don't you have like
a a kid to watch or something all right
it's like imagine I was thinking about
this I'm like imagine being so triggered
by Pearl that you just write like a
essay about me okay the the notion of
submitting to a man is no understanding
or commitment to church God and family
and serving both your husband and your
wife is the couple is doomed her message
absent of God Is A Dangerous one and a
Surefire way to accelerate feminism if
you ask me she's a controlled opposition
feminist oh dear here we go okay so let
me let me write down I just wanted to
write down her complaints
controlled
opposition I I don't even know what does
controlled opposition mean what like I
genuinely don't even know what the
like is that mean like is someone
supposed to be paying me because if
someone was paying me that would be
amazing but you know what I mean it's
like okay okay ex feminists have every
right and it is amazing when they switch
their decisions when an only fans woman
or gets off of only fans I Rejoice I say
that is amazing but I do not sell dreams
and tell them that you will have a
happily ever after and a man will bail
you out of that decision men will look
at your record men will look at your
past if a man determines that your
actions in the past do not qualify you
to be a wife a mother and demand a
traditional outcome in marriage it is
what it is I don't shoot the messenger
but a a lot but a lot of men are going
to look at the market today and say no I
do not want ex feminists and saying this
does not make me mean saying this does
not make me evil and this can be backed
up by data so Morgan Stanley a bank that
has no bare no that is no dog in this
fight is predicting that half of women
are going to be single and
childless now and now am I the bad guy
for pointing this out the the issue is
women like this want men to sign up for
marriage regardless of the fact that
there are no virgin women on the market
only 4% of women are virgins on their
wedding days and let's break down that
4% what percent of that 4% is obese what
percent of that 4% is argumentative what
perc of that 4% was raised to be wives
there is a lack of wives on the market
and the issue is instead of looking
Inward and say you know what maybe we
just have to improve as women women will
shame men for walking away and saying oh
no I'm not signing up and then cry and
whine to Pearl when Pearl says oh no oh
no oh no don't sign up for those the the
mutual submission
chicks now uh is this on women
I often offer praise to the amazing
wives and mothers out there there are
awesome and amazing wives and mothers
and I could I could point you to many
there are women that I grew up with that
were phenomenal there are women that I
know personally my friends that are
awesome wives and mothers that truly
believe in serving and submitting to
their husbands
but do you know what the common thing
you find with those chicks those chicks
know that they are rare and most of the
time those women do not put themselves
on a pedestal and have a holier than
thou attitude so I don't know what this
controlled opposition is uh some people
are now saying I'm so tired of these
conspiracy theories they're they're
saying I'm paid by this person and that
person where are my paychecks please
please send me some money I'm waiting
it's like crazy this is crazy town